okay this I almost missed this because I
was traveling over the weekend but my
colleague John told me that there was
another one of these defeat the mandates
rallies in Los Angeles over the weekend
this is one of the most dangerous
dystopian events that I've ever seen
it's also hilarious in that they bring
in speakers that are like the most
boring speakers in the world completely
uninspiring in any way
um and every every detail about this
event is absolutely horrifying we're
going to look at some of these clips
Lara Logan spoke she's the now Fox host
who has gone completely off the rails
Jimmy Dore spoke he's a
I can't even really call him a leftist
he's sort of like a he's kind of like a
neocontrarian I guess is what I would
say
um he spoke Robert Malone spoke who's
this Doctor Who's made a lot of
Headlines by being uh skeptical of
vaccines and pushing unproven treatments
and uh this type of thing and this is
scary in every sense so let's just look
at a few of these clips first and
foremost they brought up a kid to speak
a 14 year old kid whose mannerisms and
delivery are very trumpian they brought
him up this might be the most disturbing
moment when they bring up this kid to
speak against vaccines take a look at
this
we are here in Grand Park Los Angeles
gathered do you want to know
what a new floor gathered here
because it's time
for from who there's like no mandates
left what are you talking about
this is a freedom activist lucky baseri
[Applause]
stand and fight we cannot let the
weaklings take us down the brainwashed
will not defeat US America will be
strong again and California will be
liberated people
it's got a kind of mix of the political
ignorance and scientific ignorance we've
come to expect from
the anti-vaccine movement
combined with a kind of
tent Church Revival vibe
country is in parallel
parents you know that's true but it's
imperil because people are willing to go
more people are willing to go to a rally
like this rather than to a rally to
actually solve real problems that we
have we are it is in Peril but it's it's
because of these people institution is
being disregarded as nothing more than a
piece of paper and I will not let it
stand
this is not a democratic issue this is
not a republican issue it is an American
issue
Freedom all Americans deserve to be free
our founding fathers found in this
country all right so I I am getting a
little bit nauseous I don't know how
much more of that we can do so that's
extraordinarily disturbing but then the
entire event was was just filled with
some of the most ignorant people that
don't know anything and it's the the
blind leading the blind we'll look at a
couple examples here's one guy who makes
some really strange claims about
everything including Sweden
they're gonna talk later they're coming
at around three o'clock but let me end
let me end by the critical issue here
this is a bug they're coming for your
children there is no science there's no
data we've looked at the science we
looked at the science in Sweden zero
decks zero relatively signs in Germany
we look to the dinosaurs study that was
published that showed in effect jobs one
infected child would exposed 109
contacts they followed them not one
instance of secondary transmission okay
so I don't know what he means by no one
died in Sweden like I gen I genuinely
don't know what he means if he means no
one died of covet in Sweden obviously
that's not true uh we're putting deaths
by age up on the screen if he means no
children died of covet in Sweden I mean
that's also not true fifth Sweden is has
a much smaller Sweden's like a U.S state
right I mean it is a relatively small
population
15 kids nine and younger died of covet
in Sweden eight kids 10 to 19. I mean I
don't know what he means
but obviously people died in Sweden so
that was weird then this was interesting
um Jimmy Dore spoke and he's reading off
of a piece of paper
everybody including Jimmy see he doesn't
even seem to know what he's reading and
it's just all so weird dates and
passports are the major issue of the day
with millions of people protesting
against them worldwide in fact what has
become known as the medical Freedom
Movement is arguably the biggest and
most diverse International movement in
world history really an inspiring
speaker huh
and you're part of it yeah vaccine
mandates vaccine passports are among the
most vile unconstitutional immoral
unscientific discriminatory and outright
criminal policies ever enforced upon
this population
that's the black caucus of the great
party the white supremacists
don't turn on each other I have more in
common with every person here than I do
with Bill Gates yeah and I guess what he
means is like even though he's
ostensibly on the left and this is like
a mostly right-wing nuttery rally
he has more in common with them I mean
like yeah we know that that that that
seems pretty clear another great
inspirational speaker it's hard not to
hear Dr Robert Malone speak and just
feel energy coursing through you
dignity and community
Integrity is a commitment to truth in
what you say how you live and how you
treat others
flows from respect for ourselves for
each other and for the world we live in
Community is what binds us together is
what's gone wrong
is what binds us together to each other
and gives our lives purpose
in me an absolutely electric Dr Robert
Malone reading off of a laptop
the problem is not a virus the problem
is the damage that has been done to us
as human beings and as a community
[Applause]
on the other day
[Music]
the doctor of the Roman Catholic Church
who famously said the truth is like a
lion
you don't have to defend it Let it Loose
it will defend itself well
um Naomi wolf was there she's also sort
of like someone formerly I guess
associated with the left who's gone
completely out of her mind she appears
to have almost like a psychotic event or
some kind of mania check this out
and watch out
[Applause]
faced The Rage of thousands of furious
mothers and stepmothers
and it's like what are you guys
protesting against to get I don't even
really understand what what why the
event is happening they then interviewed
a doctor Michael Huang who claims he's
treated 3 000 coveted patients and he
uses this bizarre phrase where he says
he has helped a thousand kids come off
of masks almost like some kind of drug
treatment program it's a bizarre 60
seconds of video there are some cities
that are still holding on to mass
mandates even for toddlers what would
you say to parents that are wanting to
believe maybe your message
um what would you say the Physicians
view is of children wearing masks
we have helped over a thousand kids come
off masks I have treated
what does that mean
we've this they brought them in
and we detox them and it was tough we
gave them the uh we we gave
and we got him off of The Masks it was
tough they were sweating they had the
cold sweats but we got them off The
Masks few children that with covet never
had to actively prescribe any medication
there's a tremendous stratification
between The Young and the old
young people basically
very very mild disease so no fear I need
to let the parents know do not be afraid
yeah I mean look you know it's again
most people recover and most people
recover without taking anything no they
they cite that like that should really
change our perspective most people don't
die of covid
most people don't die of covet most
people don't need any medication to
recover but that doesn't make a plan for
dealing with a pandemic is it not not
surprising and then lastly
there was anti-trans stuff at the defeat
the mandates rally as well
you tell me what the connection is
between anti-trans and anti-mass and
anti-mass and anti-vaccine in the dark
you eat when you're hungry and wait I've
got one for you I don't know if you're
ready for this right
men are not women
wait a minute wait a minute what a
powerful message
for medical Freedom there huh so an
extraordinarily dangerous event and
again the really the really scary and
horrible thing is
that people go to this stuff they these
things these movements have followers in
the United States and
um it is really scary because we we all
want to solve real problems
and when you've got a not insignificant
portion of the population buying into
this stuff what what attract really a
tragic event everyone who is there
should be absolutely humiliated
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which just makes it really easy for me
to get the vitamins and minerals that I
want every day I don't always have time
to get exactly what I want from the
foods I'm eating but that's why athletic
greens ag-1 is so great it's a solution
that gives you everything in one scoop
and you get 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals as well as probiotics so it
supports gut health it is one of the
great sort of add-ons to having proper
balanced nutrition athletic greens ag-1
has become a regular part of my day I'll
put it in a smoothie it tastes great
sometimes I'll just drink it by itself
and it's been a really great and
convenient way to get everything I would
get from a multivitamin and minerals and
probiotics that I might otherwise take
separately athletic greens is giving my
audience a free 1 year supply of vitamin
D and five free travel packs with your
first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below